ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show uh late may getting ready
for the summer
one of my favorite people the guy who
told me to start a podcast this is a
fact
yeah
what you are
what is his what is the name louis gomez
louis j gomez
i always have to say louis gomez i know
why is it so important to jay uh well i
mean look at this point it's not really
important not for you
if i didn't correct you it would be
right it would be weird it's the whole
thing it's out there yeah i just
paula tompkins if you call paul
thompkins if
he'll never be on this show
that'll never ever come up in my life i
understand his paul f hopkins on this
show yeah i uh no it doesn't really you
know what it is honestly why i use the j
truthfully
it's because when i was a child and i
was practicing my autograph
the loops of your signature yeah yeah my
order
i love that you call it an honor it was
no but i wasn't practicing my signature
i was practicing an autograph that you
were going to one day give to people
yeah i was going to one day which is a
weird thing because nobody asks for
autographs i mean nobody wants an
autograph but the j looked so good the
lewis it does
my instagram handle is tim j dylan
there's something about a j that's nice
it's it it puts that stop between the
two words donald j trump donald j trump
louis j gomez tim and i get it
we're we're talking about a lot of
things obviously the economy is a horror
yeah and you have a child
you know how much things cost food yeah
i try i try not to pay attention of
course genuinely genuinely yeah you just
don't pay attention i don't
if i i like that i'll drive myself
[ __ ] crazy dude yeah gas prices if if
my life was dictated where i was walking
around going dude
these [ __ ] gas problems
yeah
look it sucks and i know it drives the
price up of everything right but at the
same time like that's not the game i'm
playing i'm not i'm not driving down the
gas prices right so what's the point
about carrying it's a great point you
can't affect it yeah but it's just a
truism it's out there yeah it's out
there it's tough of course
i only you know you play your cards
that's what i say
i agree yeah you got you got to do what
you can do out there but you're also you
have a business you you're doing well
i'm doing all right there's a lot i'm
not doing [ __ ] tim dillon well yes
you are no i'm not
tim you know what tim did yesterday he
goes yes
he i'm in his apartment and he goes i
was like i'm gonna go buy a car
and i'm like all right that's cool
and i was telling about how big j has a
jeep yeah i was like a jeep's actually
like under the radar like a really dope
wrangler so then he was like yeah i'm
gonna get a jeep yeah and i was like
really i was like i was surprised it was
yeah i was like yeah good for the money
i like it yes and then he came back two
hours later to bring me to the gym yeah
in a [ __ ]
bentley bentley flying spur you know
like i got the drinking a jeep he's got
a [ __ ] jeep i left the apartment
thinking about getting a jeep
i did and but here's the reality
you know i didn't end up getting the g i
had not slept here's a fair point yeah i
had not slept in 48 hours i was all
[ __ ] up from australia from the jet
lag yeah when i got back and i told him
i gave him a whole big speech
about financial responsibility the night
before about how you have to save your
money things don't last forever and
eventually we're probably gonna have to
live in a state like florida you know
because it's less expensive to own
property and the taxes are better and i
said we just got to be smart about our
money of course i gave him a real big
speed and the next day i bought a
bentley bentley and yeah i've always
wanted this
rolled off the lot 30 000 just melts off
of it immediately well sure that's yeah
of course but here's the other thing
um
those cars do have a resale
a decent resale yeah because
there's always going to be somebody that
wants that car
it's not gonna be as much it's i you
know what's fun it's just a car that i
would never i would never get that car
it's incredible it's beautiful right
yeah but i just feel like if i were to
get that car i would also need a driver
like ben should be driving you around
hey by the way by the way agreed yeah it
really should be yeah
hey hey hey hey
zero argument for me
zero argument for me
uh in that in that thing well then we're
in such different worlds right like he
pulled in
i thought we're going i thought we were
going to his apartment before we were
going to lunch yesterday yeah and he
pulls him to the beverly hills hotel
yeah and i sort of take my bags out of
the back thinking he's like i don't live
here you [ __ ] idiot yeah yeah i was
like no no
well it's it's a um
we've been lucky because
we have a friend who has a really really
big podcast and he's had me on a bunch
and he's the most influential podcaster
in the world his name is tony inch club
and by doing that show so many times i
was exposed to lots of people yeah and i
was able to get it get a a a big group
of people listening so we're we're happy
about that um i also don't have kids i'm
not gonna have kids i don't have a
family
it allows me to kind of misbehave
for you to buy a bentley instead of
funding your kids college is criminal
right criminal of course but that's the
freedom
you know you you know you do those
things yeah
because you know you feel [ __ ] good
and that's nice fuels
something else that is harder yeah you
know so it's like if you want to [ __ ]
have a bentley you're not you're not
going backwards now tim no and that is
an investment into your own self-belief
and your own sort of way of doing things
and
i look at spending money as an
investment i i take stupid vacations you
know i try to have nice things you know
right um i just i'm classless
so when i say nice things like i got an
inflatable hot tub and i'm like dude i'm
[ __ ] killing it right right right
right i'm not uh you have nice things
people would get with marlborough miles
you know what i mean like nice things
that would come out of a cigarette
catalog
you'll get you know like
a marlborough leather jacket
though you'll get a tent one of those
red tents they used to have there's
nothing wrong with it it's beautiful
these are beautiful things dude i would
look at the marble miles catalog in awe
being like wow dude yeah all of these
things you could get none of it matters
the only thing that matters is uh
friends and family yeah
now
here's the difference though it is a it
is all of these things are inherently
dumb
anything you buy is kind of stupid but
it makes you feel good and it's it's a
nice thing yeah and and that's all it is
right i mean they're not they don't
change your life but they give you maybe
a little bit of joy in a you know world
where you need uh every now and then you
need a little joy i think you and
worthwhile investments are your home
your car right you know wherever you're
spending a lot of time to yourself
thinking quote unquote meditating we
don't [ __ ] meditate anymore but right
when you're driving you can't really be
texting i mean i do right you know sure
um but when you when you're driving like
you you're alone with your thoughts you
listen to music but you start thinking
through your life and all that [ __ ] and
if you're in a [ __ ] shitty car you're
gonna just feel like [ __ ] in my opinion
yes i think it's i've been in a shitty
car i used to drive a oldsmobile 88 not
even a year that's the type of car
and you it would literally like when i
when i would press the brake too hard
the car would shut off yeah like i i
i've been in mitsubishi a lot i've been
in all pieces
i just i would just buy
for years yeah the cheapest car at the
used car dealership like not like a used
car dealership like like a certified
pre-owned toyota talking about like a
guy
who and this one
is certified pre-owned this is a
certified pre-owned bentley good 2018.
it's not brand new you don't have to
tell people that well but here's the
reality it's no different than a 2021
but or 2022 but people ask my friends
can you look up the differences between
the 2022 and the 2018. there's very few
there's going to be a handful of them
but there's not that many what were you
saying definitely not a high-tech car
meaning like
it doesn't have like the runner lights
like when you get into bentley it
doesn't you know it's not like a new
beamer or a mercedes right where they
have the pink and purple designed by a
puerto rican yeah it looks kind of
ethnic
it looks a little ethnic
um you know the reality is this is more
of an english gentleman's car it doesn't
it doesn't have a horn that goes beep
and it didn't idiot yeah right right
yeah this isn't a you know
so
there's my new my audi like literally
half the technology is being able to
change the lighting panels and
everything right
some people like when they get in a car
to for it to be lit up and to feel like
a you know some type of carnival yeah
because that's where they work or that's
where they they're good family memories
are going to a free carnival it's a
simple way
yeah they're treating they're treating
people like morons they're going you
like flashing lights don't you yeah and
we do yeah i love it for sure i mean
there's nothing there's nothing if i
want to if i was i could match my
lighting scheme to my outfits yeah they
sold it to me that way they looked at me
when they they're like that this
portrait guy is going to love this
feature right and they said they're like
you can match the lighting scheme every
day to whatever outfit you're wearing
and i was like what the [ __ ] is wrong
yeah i mean it's that's such a so the
new one is going to probably i don't
even know these d what these differences
are i mean they both have a v8 engine
right yeah i have a sport i have a sport
package which they don't even make
anymore which is faster my engines might
be even better
and this is the uh this is the uh 2018
right here
four liter v8 the same [ __ ] yeah same
[ __ ] i mean
you know and again if you look go to the
interior of the 2020 i mean by the way
is this not a relatable segment this is
like the least relatable of the 20 i
mean there are people i have people
watching this overdosing on heroin right
now
but if you look at it look at it yeah go
to the next one ben go to the right
right can i tell you why it's relatable
yeah yeah tell me why because they
[ __ ] oh they watched you dude i
remember yeah i remember tim once a
month would ask me for an advance on his
i would 600 a month podcast payout i
would and like the 27th would hit and
yeah he's like dude i need the money i
need i need it in cash i know and you'd
give it to me
and that would upload a photo an hour
later at a steakhouse
[ __ ] wood
but it's 75
it's inspiring for people to watch you
this is why people like you that is
[ __ ] relatable it's like you're not
yeah you're not [ __ ] gifted anything
dude you've been hustling and grinding
for a while yeah no i've been it's 12
years yeah it's a long time it's a
really long time i think people see it
like this
best years of my life are over and they
were poor yeah like the vast majority of
my life i would have rather have this
money at 21 yeah because you have more
energy it's more it's cooler that's why
the la peop now obviously i have more
perspective now and blah blah blah but
the l.a life that these tick tockers
live is what's supposed to happen you
get famous at 18.
you're famous until you're 25 and then
you die 27 or 28.
and because it doesn't get better
and you did it and you were famous at
the best time to be famous you didn't
work for it you didn't know what it was
you had no now we have perspective
it's you know but there's something nice
about just getting a whole bunch of [ __ ]
you don't even know why you have it yeah
and all of it's just fun i i don't even
understand how i got laid when i was in
my twenties i was so poor yeah and dirty
yeah my body right was dirty what were
you doing as for worse selling comedy
club tickets right when i first started
in comedy i was selling comedy club
tickets yeah and then um
i mean i would just [ __ ] be out there
like i was a street kid dude i was like
just a [ __ ] like we'd smoke blunts
and stairwells and drink 40s on stoops
and
and there'd be like women that i'd hook
up and like i think back now i'm like
how would any woman ever
like yeah i'm like a shitty comedian
like just not like like how do you like
how do you how does a woman spread her
legs for an unfunny comedian that's a
crazy thing he's trying to be funny many
of them do it's a crazy by the way many
of them have big houses with unfunny
comedians and live very well oh i'm very
sure they do very well yeah we were
talking about um
people that don't have money that want
to go on vacation and we wanted to give
a
kind of a
uh
guide to people that don't have a lot
that need to take their kids somewhere
because it's my belief that
you got to go on a summer vacation even
if
you don't leave your town
like some people don't want to stay
that's terrible it's sad that's garbage
it's very hard you shouldn't do that
have you but you you've even seen that i
was uh yeah i see that all the time but
i was in could we go on the road a lot
so we're in hotels and you'll just see
uh this happened last weekend in
providence there's a family in the pool
and i'm like in my mind i'm going like
why would anybody visit providence right
and then they were like oh we're from
newport we're like 40 minutes away from
here we just like did a staycation
i look at this poor little
three-year-old and i wanted to kidnap
him and just release him into the
parking lot that would be a better one
nicer area so it's weird that they went
to providence so what's going on is like
the dad's into something weird or the
mom is there's no reason you go from
newport to providence for staycation
something's going on they wanted the
pool
that was it there's pools in newport i
don't know something's up they wanted to
get out of town i don't know but it was
it was i felt so bad
i think about that all the time i'll be
at like
yeah a gig in atlantic city and you'll
see a family
it's tough it's [ __ ] brutal dude and
you see a family just at a shitty hotel
and it's usually like an indoor pool it
smells bad i might do that with my
family as like a joke like i might i
might bring my whole family to atlantic
city
to be funny as a bit as like a bit yeah
like we're all in on and we're gonna
like you know yeah and then just bring
them and go here's uh welcome to the i
mean i did that when i was a kid so my
friend rocky who uh ended up being gay
he tried to suck my dick when we were
like in the sixth grade so i always knew
he was playing with barbies when he was
a kid yeah real uh you know real tim
dillon yeah what's he up to now uh he
sells real estate does he do well i
don't know uh but i stay in touch here
and there you know but he [ __ ] uh now
he's very very out but his family
we were so poor right i thought his
family was rich right
his family lived in like a nice trailer
a
nice a particularly nice trail
that's how rough it was yeah it was i
[ __ ] you not dude and they would take me
on their family vacations and i'm like
wow dude we go to bali's in atlantic
city yeah
his dad's just throwing bones at valleys
you're like ah it's your fresh prince of
bel-air yes and the guy you're you're
driving in a trailer to balance this was
i i mean yeah dude i think back it's so
funny how poor this family was yeah and
how i and they looked down their nose at
me like i remember feeling like i was
like i
i grew up we didn't have a ton of money
yeah like i had an in i had a backyard
pool it was an in-ground pool but it was
six feet so when you dove into it you
had to dive out like you couldn't dive
down yeah and a lot of my friends had
the eight foot ten foot pool twelve foot
pool was much larger when you when you
were to jump in you could dive straight
down so when you but when you
when you're up in the air and you
realize i can't dive straight down i
have to dive out to me that's what
poverty is that's important the thought
the thought of how deep is the pool is
poverty to me because a big pool where
you don't even worry about how deep it
is because it just is deep
we have you just it that to me is we use
or so our landlord
when we were kids
mary leone
she was this [ __ ] old white lady
she's still around no she's very dead
but long dead but her
her
niece and nep or i guess her grandkids
right they were like these kids they
were like you know they just had like
the fun toys but once again these people
were all trashed none of these people
were rich like no none of them but they
had like a an in-ground pool but there
was like algae in it it just wasn't yeah
that's a [ __ ] garbage ass family
and uh i remember they would just like
be in the pool they would invite us in
sometimes but literally one of the
biggest like cringy things in my life i
think back is just one time i was like
standing in the pool wanting them to
invite me in right and like just staring
and i think i was like i want to go back
in time and just [ __ ]
tell yourself don't do that what are you
[ __ ] doing dude have some pride the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
go get your own pool right yeah yeah
where where
would you and your family go on a trip
did you ever take a vacation my mom
would take us they now i i remember
and this was she was a little she did
drugs my mom was a heroin addict a
prostitute and a prostitute and i knew
this i knew my mom was a prostitute for
as long as i remember because i remember
my
there was like this old guy who was my
sister's godfather actually and i caught
them like naked in bed together
and i remember even at like three or
four years old just thinking i was like
well she's not [ __ ] him for pleasure
i was like she's being paid for this and
i just sort of connected the dots even
as a young child young child i i just
knew i i sort of it was you know i just
knew that's what it was
yeah were you proud a little bit
yeah
i was collecting i was collecting a
commission it is no it's to me i got her
the gig dude to me there's something
about that that is a little bit you go
hey mom is
really working
mommy's
working no
no i didn't i think i sort of blocked it
from my memory for a while yeah like i i
didn't like but i think back now i just
remember having the thought that this is
for [ __ ] money
um so yeah my mom was [ __ ] trash so
we were just really really poor you know
she wasn't she wasn't a high-end
prostitute either like right honestly if
you're a host by the way you don't need
to say that well that's crazy though i
appreciate that you
you don't need to say i love that you
have to you go just in case anyone out
there was wondering uh my mother
she was not hired she was an attractive
woman in fact if you go on my own oh
she's afraid you know high-end
prostitutes not only attractive it's
like it's a whole thing
no they gotta be kind of they're hot
well they gotta be hot first and
foremost they gotta be hot all right go
to my instagram right now you gotta have
the money to travel grandmother's day
okay go down right to the right that's
my mom with the red hair okay right here
okay right here my mom
cleaned up
no she's pretty she's a pretty woman she
cleaned up yeah okay that's my sister
right there
now
she would not be able to try it look at
you and your sister this is what i think
and i say to myself
god bless this woman because i would
have abandoned you kids
instead of [ __ ] like instead of [ __ ]
to feed you too which by the way you're
clearly fed
[Laughter]
i would have abandoned you too
immediately like at a truck stop
new jersey no but good for her she i
mean i respect one another what a sad
family photo
one growing up one of my women that i
looked up to was a prostitute my
friend's mother and she would explain to
us how she was always a prostitute she
was still kind of a prostitute and she
took all that money and invested it in
stocks and knew all about the market and
she was very interesting
oh yeah that's crazy yeah my mom didn't
do any of that my mom bought heroin with
it yeah and i think when she was hard up
for heroin i think her prices would drop
dramatically right yeah then it was just
kind of a but she would be a 300 an hour
hooker right did you mid-range did she
ever admit it to you
no we never got there you never broached
it never never got there she uh were
there men coming and going or would you
well that's what this we're paying her
for
but would you notice like different guys
around no so this is when this is
when i was really young i don't think
she was hooking when i was like at an
age where i really had memories of it
gotcha so i was like three or four well
that was nice of her yeah you know she
ended up you know becoming a hairdresser
which is actually
i have less respect for hairdressers
oh much less i mean but here's what's
nice about her
she didn't sell you or your sister some
prostitutes like you know
you know what i mean yeah i mean in
fairness to her was a hard sell that
would have been a tough salary you and
your sister i mean that would have been
a very rough
laggy you got to be in the bull if
you're into both of us that's a lot well
you got to be a pedophile and kind of
blind be into fat cholos yeah you got to
be you got to have a fat solo fetish as
a pedophile
like imagine are there those pedophiles
that go to epstein's island and they're
like yeah i know you got all these thin
you know white kids but like i want fat
cholesterol fat mexican kids not hot
eastern europe i want gathering of the
juggalos
solos
like yeah so we our vacations that i
remember we would go to seaside heights
in new jersey
and i just right i remember because it's
nice because it's the beach and she
could score she could probably josh
could probably just find heroin on the
beach right so yeah um and what would
that entail she said hacks would you get
a room somewhere i think we would get
she called it a cabin
but i okay what i remember it as was
like a shed and there was like one
building that's almost like a shed with
a couple beds yeah you could enter in on
either side right very very vague
memories of these seaside heights
probably like 15 bucks a night something
like that right something really really
[ __ ] cheap when you say enter on
either side i'm thinking like public
restroom kind of yeah like that i
my memories were like there was like
three bathrooms there were no beds and
you could enter on either side and there
were hand dryers on each side of the
wall to dry your hands
and she would set up
a bag sleeping bag for me and my sister
on the floor of this so you would stay
for two nights a night probably
something like that two nights i i don't
even remember
audit semi-annual sale is here featuring
the lowest price of the year on our most
popular supplements food equipment and
more for two weeks only all of our
products will be on sale at huge
discounts save 25 off supplements like
alpha brain the memory and focus
supplement that sold over 1 million
bottles or total human the convenient
day and night packs complete with
essential vitamins minerals herbs and
amino acids which make optimization easy
take 20 off all nutrition products and
stock up on some grass-fed whey protein
or the extremely delicious and
nutritious protein bites 10 off fitness
equipment like primal kettlebells and
steel mesas and 50 off all digital on at
6 programs including on a six body
weight and on at six barbell plus get up
to sixty percent of door busters like
hydro tech instant and shroom tech green
and exclusive free gifts too but hurry
the on at semi annual sale ends today
may 29th and all products will go back
to their regular prices don't miss out
on the best deals of the year learn more
on it.com jam that's on it.com
tim and full disclosure this is the
company that was started uh uh and
invested in by marc maron
oh really yeah
i like the protein bites have you ever
had them oh yeah they're in rogan's
vending machine they're very tasty
i
love that i take the alpha brain now
yeah baby
i like an amino acid you guys know i
love breaking protection that my simply
safe home security system gets me but
it's not always outside forces that you
need to simply save protection from this
is joshua's story a simply safe customer
from indiana a few months ago he fell
asleep with pizza rolls still in the
oven that could have been disastrous
thousands of dollars in damage to his
kitchen home maybe even worse luckily
joshua had a comprehensive simply safe
system equipped with everything to
prevent break-ins and smoke detectors to
sniff out fires he was startled awake to
the sound of a 95 decibel alarm from his
simply safe base station
seconds later he got a call from simply
say professional monitoring the pete's
roles didn't make it
but josh did he believes simply safe
probably saved his life that night wow
wow
i love it i love because often i'll put
things in my oven and then go to sleep
and simply safe will prevent me from
being cooked like a pizza roll
protecting people when the guard is down
is just one of the reasons more than 4
million people use and love simply safe
and with a comprehensive simply save
system 24 7 professional monitoring
because that's what you need the
monitoring that's what makes it
different right oh yeah because people
are actually monitoring it they care
so if you're laying there like a big lug
with a bunch of pizza rolls about to
blow up your whole house
somebody's going look at this schmuck
and they help you
um i use this you use it
you can customize the perfect system for
your home in just a few minutes it's
simply safe.com tim dillon go today and
claim a free indoor security camera plus
20 off with interactive monitoring go to
simplysave.com tim dillon that's
simplysafe.com
tim dillon
the best the best vacation my mom ever
took us on yeah god this is gonna be
rough it's gonna be so sad because
here's why it's gonna be so sad you've
specified that this is the best this is
the top of the line top of the line
vacation my mother ever took us on
hartford connecticut oh my god
wrestlemania 11. now it was cool that's
kind of cool because it was not bad that
was actually not we were a massive pro
wrestling fan give it up for hey
give it up for this [ __ ] she she did it
was the one [ __ ] thing she really she
spent the money like you know i think at
the time the tickets were probably 75
bucks a pop which is a lot of money yeah
a lot of them now that's [ __ ] cool as
far as like you know 20 rows back maybe
you saw us on camera where like along
the gate you know you and your sister me
and my sister it was the best time ever
they did they do a fan festival that's
actually all the wrestlers now i feel
bad no don't feel bad but very
influential if you look at the fan the
wrestlemania fan festival if you what we
do with skank fest like that was like
one of the best memories the
wrestlemania fans festival you show up
and it's not just [ __ ] like
autographs they have a lot of
interactive [ __ ] you know you're like
you know you're you're you're meeting
the wrestlers you do meet and greets and
[ __ ] but they're like doing [ __ ]
other things it's like shows have no
it's hilarious stan hope goes on rogan
and brings up how cool skank fest is
ridiculous and then rogen just shuts it
down immediately and goes you should do
your own fest
and he's trying to like have a nice
pitch
it's a nice pitch
he's like i did this festival it's just
the greatest thing ever yeah rogan's
like he's like he was like oh yeah he's
like that's really probably because the
comedy scene down in houston is great
it's like there's nothing to do with the
comedy scene yeah it's [ __ ] houston
it's nothing we booked three comics from
houston we brought the [ __ ] greatest
comics from the world mostly from new
york city to houston and [ __ ] did the
most unique fun interactive craziest
comedy festival ever yeah but doug stand
up should just steal the idea yeah
you should just take it
joe's like you should do your own the
same guy who assaulted carlos mancia for
stealing a shitty
was just like steal it do you wrong
well it's not stealing you just said do
your own fast i think no i i think he's
a little disconnected from what
skankfest is i think he thinks like
that's what bert's still by the way i
hope he's just he's got he's worth
hundreds of millions of dollars i hope
he's disconnected from it yeah but i
mean like bert you know bert's doing his
own festival it's not the same thing
though right it's not there's there's
nothing like scanning first you got to
go and see it and know what it is in
order to [ __ ] and now what is what
would you say the difference with
skankfest is it's if people get raised
it's a part well yeah well they don't
tell yeah it's a party here's the thing
that's great
the [ __ ] whatever they call it the idea
that's what is the joke festival here's
what i will say about skankfest it is an
immersive experience meaning that it is
three days
it involves not only going to see
stand-up but you have like other events
that comedians go to and will be at and
you can like mix with live podcast is
fighting pro wrestling there's [ __ ]
just there's mechanical bulls and
[ __ ] games and
beer pong tournaments and
it's stupid it's a fun thing it's a fun
thing it's a woodstock for people that
like podcasts it's the best podcast fans
in the world best comedy fans of the
world they they they love comedy they
love every time i've done a show it's
gang fest it's always been great and
every time we've done a live podcast
it's gang fast yeah it's always been
great can we see it we're gonna do
bastard radio yeah it'll be fine i'm
forcing you it'll be fun no i'm doing it
i told you i would do it right now
absolutely we'll do it me and the great
nick mullen uh i think we're gonna do a
state of the industry address as bastard
radio the biggest topics from the year
we're going to break down
i just want to cover please
if we do a state of the industry address
we've got to carve out gringo poppy who
does what i want to do la i want to do
the region no no i want to do the state
of the la podcasting
as part of the as part of the state of
the industry addresses skankfest yeah
you and nick can do everything else yeah
everything else that's yours
you guys cover all of new york
television and film every podcast in the
world other than and you could also
comment on the state of the la
podcasting of course of course but i
would like to delete it my
expertise i just want to do the state of
the la podcast scene the great enduring
scene that will never die can we and
it'll be called the la podcasting the
scene that will never die and it will
have the photos of the people who are
currently in prison
[Laughter]
tim can we play word association la
comic scene sure all right ready
you gotta just fire it off don't be a
[ __ ] whitney cummings
drugs
bobby lee
korean
i mean it's the first thing that comes
to mind ryan cowan
ruffia
gringo poppy
kind of brilliant
kind of brilliantly
brilliantly funny in a way that no
comedy special has ever been
because it's it's mysterious in a way
because you're looking at it and you're
going like there's a lot of choices made
and you don't know why those choices
were made of course
of course yeah the comedy store uh
fine
that's it i can't name another word i
mean that's you know yeah
well here's what's amazing about the
gringo poppy
this is what's truly amazing about it
okay
you're watching it
and you're in kind of it's it's
you're in a little bit of disbelief
because it is
i i wonder and i know he's trying to get
good at stand up and i respect the hell
out of that the question is did it have
to be a special
no
that's the real question no
no it didn't yeah yeah and i'm not one
of these guys who like that's not that's
on brett that's not [ __ ] he's a nice guy
and i know he's trying to be you know
like but the question is with that
particular thing you go did that have to
be i said this on real-life podcast he
should have friends going because here's
the thing he is a charming dude right
yes um and he i think
i don't know at all you know but i think
there's probably something he's probably
a funny he probably makes his friends
laugh right yeah i think that he's
really great at podcasting on that
specific show for that audience yeah
which they want mma there's an audience
of people in america that want what he
does and he does it for them i am not
that audience of course but that's fair
but that's fair and here's the thing
yeah we we all go out because i don't
care about you everyone stinks at comedy
for the first five ten years twenty
thirty years there's a [ __ ] minimum
of five that's so if you get good and
start getting [ __ ] under five five
that's like fast that's rare that's fast
one of the michael j like who's my best
friend and he's one of the people we're
talking about guys that like they got
like it's rare very rare yeah very rare
and you see it and you're like god damn
dude those guys got good and they got
good yes and they started getting things
i was pretty rare i got pretty good
pretty quickly but
again i didn't really pop until i
started doing this yeah of course that
was what i needed to do so but that's
the thing that's like the stand-up is
kind of gay
when we came up you stand up's kind of
gay and dumb yeah let's be honest it's
when i watch brendan do that
it's like i i i go here's a big tough
guy
who i should just see in a ferrari and
he should be able to rip people's faces
off with his catcher mid hands and i see
him running around the stage going oh
i go you're gay now you've become gay
you were you why are you gay he was
a [ __ ] knight
and you go what why
what is this disease of god maybe they
should come out next week what is it
you're six foot
you're six foot six you're an adonis you
could beat up 99 of the people who look
forward [ __ ] women and you don't have to
[ __ ] these skanks at the comedy
and instead he's fully gay
on stage in dallas in front of 45 people
being like
it's just
it's puzzling
it's uh yeah you don't need it when you
don't need it but that's the thing like
um
you know i i don't i i feel i feel bad
[ __ ] on his comedy because i don't
[ __ ] on people's comedy no no no me
saying you shouldn't be a comedian is
the highest respect i can pay you
if if i look at you and go you shouldn't
really do comedy it's me going
you are better than this i truly believe
he's like better than this yeah we all
know until you start to do this this was
nobody's a plan nobody no i was in a
little kid being like dude i want to
[ __ ] dance like a monkey for
strangers right and and pray to god that
they like me and that they react to my
words in a club yes or i won't feel
anything that's right that's crazy
that's a [ __ ] that's pathetic really
honestly if if aliens came down and
watched us doing comedy it's gay making
these songs i don't even mean gay like
having sex with men i mean like it's
just cringe yeah a little yeah it's a
little bit i feel embarrassed that i
need the validation of strangers and
others should too and even though we
make people happy it comes from the need
and i just feel like knowing that
i would give up your happiness
for my happiness so everyone knows their
happiness is inconsequential in this
means nothing like what people say to me
they're like your podcast got me through
the quarantine i'm like you have no idea
what it's done for me
i'm like i'm glad it's helped you and it
makes me feel good that's helped them
but i liked you
being honest your mom died
yeah i'm like i'm glad it helped you but
it really helped me
you know dude i'm [ __ ] having a weird
[ __ ] muscle spasm in my stomach
why because i did sit ups for the first
time ever
oh not ever like yesterday but but my
point is that when i tell somebody hey
stan it may not be for you it's not it
doesn't it's not an egg no it's not and
uh yeah whatever you just don't need to
put out specials david tell puts out a
special every eight years and he's one
of the greatest of all time why is
brandon shaw putting out two spells i
don't even love the special that i just
shot and it's coming out because here's
the deal it's like it's i wrote the
material two years ago you saw the jokes
two years ago at vinnie brandt's stress
factory but my whole thing is i want to
do it live as much as i can so by the
time the special comes out a lot of it's
topical it's relevant i don't love it i
don't i didn't love the audience
it is what it is but you know i
i whatever people want to do with their
lives they can do yeah that's worse we
live in america more power to them yeah
we live in america more power to them
yeah for sure um um
do do you think brennan shopping on
vacation
someone nice probably somewhere nice
probably somewhere nice everybody's
trying to steal your information
companies governments that's why you
need expressvpn every time you connect
to an unencrypted network cafes hotels
airports any hacker on the same network
can gain access to your personal data
passwords financial details it doesn't
take much technical knowledge to hack
someone just some cheap hardware is
needed a smart 12 year old could do it
if your data is valuable hackers can
make a thousand per person selling
personal info on the dark web it's time
for expressvpn they've got an encrypted
tunnel that creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between you and your service and
internet hackers cannot steal your
sensitive data it's super secure it
would take a hacker with a super
computer over 8 billion years to get
past express uh vpn's encryption it's
easy to use fire up the app and click
one button to get protected works on all
devices phones laptops tablets and more
so you can stay secure on the go i use
it ben uses it we all use expressvpn and
we love it i'm telling you you know what
i like most about it it's easy it's
simple
it's like in australia remember how
useful it was changing yes
we wanted to watch netflix and they
don't have the new ozark yet ozark sucks
anyway secure your online data today by
ex visiting
expressvpn.com tim dillon that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com tim dillon and you can get an
extra three months free what
what
extra three months free expressvpn.com
tim dillon everybody's running an online
business now it's so important and you
need to be focusing on growing your
business you don't need to focus on
shipping that's why you need to use ship
station they're a virtual back office
that handles everything that could cause
you any type of uh headache
you get deeply discounted shipping rates
normally reserved for fortune 500
companies ship station works with over 5
or 45 carriers easily compare rates and
delivery times to quickly find the best
option every time works with over 300
platforms like amazon ebay etsy and more
to automate processes like fulfillment
and tracking so you could save time
managing orders 98 of companies that use
shipstation for one year keep using it
for as long as they're in business don't
let the big guys keep all the good
discounts to themselves sign up using
promo code tim dillon that's tim dillon
d-i-l-o-n for a free 60-day trial at
shipstation.com and start saving with
every shipment we talk to a lot of sam
talent a lot of people use shipstation
for everything they do and they save a
shitload of money ship station is great
you get two months of discounted
shipping absolutely free go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in tim
dillon you go to shipstation.com click
on the microphone at the top of the page
and type in tim dillon make ship happen
where'd you go on vacation as a kid the
enchanted forest look this up this is a
place called the enchanted forest my
parents took me there i'm almost
positive they were trying to sell me to
human traffickers is this uh yeah i
think a renaissance type fair uh
it's ah where is it ben yeah this says
it's in oregon but are you talking about
no you went to germany no it's like in
like [ __ ] it's in like upstate new york
and it was by canada maybe it's in
upstate new york and it was like this
weird place that they i'm i'm pretty
sure they were trying to sell me
enchanted force waters yeah it's yeah an
old forge yeah yeah old forge this place
okay the enchanted fog it's like a water
park
that's probably pretty cool though
yeah they got this guy
paul bunyan
it was like one of those things where i
think they thought it was going to be
good like that's the other thing
you know it sucks when like the coolest
characters they have are like old
yeah it's like humpty dumpty like they
couldn't afford they couldn't get
anybody [ __ ] like sesame places yeah
no and i we'd do that we went to hershey
park we went to sesame place
uh we went to
uh my dad when they got divorced my dad
took me to cool places because i want
like because then it was like okay i
don't have to deal with your mother yeah
well that's going on now and then it's
also yeah you know here's what happens
when you're divorced that cause i'm like
yeah you know me and my my son's mother
we co-parent and i do a father's day
trip with him every year yeah and i just
let him spin the globe that's right
point wherever he wants to go wherever
he wants to go whoa look he's stupid
he's nine he's a child right and he
can't spend that much yeah i can i can
[ __ ] sort of
goad him into what if he spins a globe
and he's like i want to go to sierra
leone
i want to go to diamond to find blood
diamonds
but my dad would take me to nice places
because my mother wasn't involved well
he wants to say he wants it's a [ __ ] you
to the mom oh i want my son
when he grows up to be able to tell his
mother like i went to all these places
without you i went to [ __ ] rome this
summer because my dad took me to a great
kids trip and i told i told louis is
australia
because it's just too far but it's a
great kid's trip because the animals all
that stuff the zoos it's a very cool
trip you know it's very cool uh it's
just a lot to do 20 hours on a flight
with a kid it's too much
yes a little bit older i'll do it with
him for sure he's a mature kid too yeah
yeah we're going to rome this uh this
summer that's amazing yeah my parents
never took me i mean we took one trip to
europe when i was five that my
grandfather paid for and the whole
family went and i was so sick the doctor
goes don't put him on a plane and my
mother father went well we're going to
europe so he's going
[Music]
there's literally a photo of me on
instagram a long time ago where i'm
literally like a sick four-year-old on a
cross you know going overseas to europe
yeah that's crazy yeah
i didn't fly until i was
19. yeah 19 was the first time i was on
a flight i went to fort lauderdale
florida yeah with my girlfriend yeah
like a you know they regret it was her
graduation trip i graduated the year
before right um it was my girl and then
the uh lead singer of coheed in cambria
oh was dating my girlfriend's best
friend so he was on this trip as well oh
and she's just no coed and cambrie i've
heard of them it's like a gay emoji
they do okay right they're great they're
really talented they're like like very
progressive almost like a new age rush
okay they're [ __ ]
yeah but yeah i don't care yeah they
were cool but well good yeah that was my
first time on a flight it's difficult uh
night right now with
with the
you know
a lot of families are having a tough
time
taking their kids
you know
places yeah and
that
i think can be alleviated a little bit
by trying to figure out like where did
let's look up where you went you went to
a place okay so uh people confused port
aransas and south padre island south
padre is actually nice and people give
me a lot of [ __ ] for saying south padres
no it's not first of all it's not nice i
don't think it is [ __ ] or animals shut
the [ __ ] up yeah because this is there's
nine nice places in the country the
hamptons malibu beverly hills palm beach
jackson hall aspen there's like 10
places that are [ __ ] nice and florida
parts of it so the place i went actually
yeah porter ransas yeah this shit's all
f everything you guys are naming is
fancy as [ __ ] to me yes like i i you
know
we shouldn't go on vacations we didn't
go to sleep by the way they're making
this look better in the things they do
this all the time they light in the
water they make it look a certain type
of blue and then you get there and it's
not that
but that's what it is and then that's
what it ends up being so that's what it
is
that's what it is
that's what it is and then ben would go
there with his family they stayed like a
motel and uh they'd eat like what would
you eat like imitation crab yeah eat
like fake crab
and and that's rough
i never had it that bad like other than
my mother was a schizophrenic and my fam
i had a very loveless
a family of people who hated each other
and i had the gay thing where you had to
stay i see keep who you are secretive
and i was a drug addict but i we never
were there was there anybody
was there anybody who found out you were
gay before you came out and you're like
dude you gotta [ __ ] keep this under
wraps a few people i sucked off had
suspicions
they were suspicious but they didn't
they didn't go um no yeah i mean there
are people that thought so but nobody
like found out like to find out you'd
have to have like proof yeah i didn't i
didn't believe you were gay for like a
year yeah
he's not gay no i mean it's still very
much people don't believe it but it's
only because they don't know people
like if you meet people you meet gay
people that are not like what you see on
tv well i think that's an act very often
it's performative very old some of it is
but some guys are just very effeminate
but then some guys take it to the next
level well they lean into it they don't
know there's a choice at one point all
black like gangsters if you're really
black you're leaning into it yeah like
if you're real you know what i mean i
watch well i watch people i watch like
uh you know people that lean in dude i
i watch
i watch some of my black friends and
they
they i watch them write like in ebonics
yeah on like social media yeah and i'm
like i know you have auto correct you
have to go through so much trouble
[Laughter]
to write that way yeah why would you
spend the time it's so much more effort
to [ __ ] it's that identity yeah it's
an identity and you lean in
what's interesting about you is you're
you're a puerto rican white supremacist
you know as you say in the press
i'm a truth teller right
but what's interesting about you is you
and me
bond in this way that we're we we that
stuff's gross to us when the identity
politics gets like we're not ashamed of
who we are we don't we don't hide any of
it
uh yes i pretend to have a wife and yes
you tell people you're italian
[Laughter]
no but we don't there's something about
us we just we're not into the group
thing no we're not also don't get it
done yeah social media is training
people to
you know put themselves out there in a
certain way right and you and i both
yeah right i think we recognize
number one what's funnier but yes what's
better what's more relatable to sort of
like really be much more real versions
of ourselves you get a very real version
of me and a very real version of you on
these shows right right i think you know
a lot of other people they're very
protected in what they do and how they
present themselves um and in comedy it's
less so i think comedy and podcasting
much less so and i think you and i much
less so than a lot of our peers yeah our
peers that do it as well so
you know that's um
you know that's you know it's just
phoniness you know you sort of see i was
i tweeted this norman is a black woman
it's like never now
you have no idea who he is
yeah but i tweeted this the other day
you'll see people who on instagram will
respond to every comment right so you
can write a comment and then write heart
face emoji whatever thank you love you
and what those people are doing is
they're manipulating the algorithm like
instagram will move your content further
up um and show it to more people if
you're engaging with everybody right so
it's just
and it's a sociopathic thing and it's
usually like hot checks but they respond
to everything and they're like heart
love you thank you you're like dude
you're just like blind you know like
blindly just going and saying that to
everybody to and pretending to like
these people and pretending to have a
real relationship with them just to
manipulate an algorithm it's sick it's
sickening it's really sick it's [ __ ]
psychotic it's crazy um so we see people
do very well like that no no you anybody
who's famous on instagram any instagram
model any tick talker they all do that's
all they do that's all they do it's a
part of their job the same way you have
to [ __ ] you're in your job you answer
emails in the morning it's their job to
go in very often they have social media
managers that are doing it and they
respond to every single thing you'll see
it yeah any influencer they respond to
every single thing and what
and it just again i guess it just
bolsters this idea that you're the this
is this community you're part of you're
an active member of it well i think most
people go over to respond this is great
and they feel that thing and that's why
they're there and then it's very
reciprocal yeah and then they respond to
yeah but i don't know dude i just i
respond to a lot of people on social
media but not everybody right it's just
not a [ __ ] you know like if somebody
sends me a dm if i'm in if i'm traveling
you might get a response very often i'll
respond occasionally yeah dude just some
random [ __ ] person and like oh thanks
dude appreciate it yeah but then you
know it bites you in the ass i have a
guy right now i wish dude
i guess he dm me a while ago and i
responded he dm me again i was like
driving or something i just saw it i
didn't say anything it's fine
and then he [ __ ] dms me again because
i saw that with like middle fingers like
oh dude i guess you're too cool for me
now like dude we're not friends like i
just i responded to you once so
whatever dude you damn defeated if you
damned if you don't you know but i don't
[ __ ] play those
games where you're trying to just
manipulate an algorithm you're trying to
you know trying to game the system
instead of just being good instead of
being funny or being interesting it's a
lot of gaming the system and that's what
la is a lot of right for sure there's a
lot of people that they didn't come up
and they didn't go through those months
where they were [ __ ] they didn't know
where they were gonna eat they didn't
know how they were gonna [ __ ] pay
their rent they didn't even you know
they just you know
it worked out very quickly for a lot of
these people you know and it was a lot
less of a struggle out here it seems
yeah
a lot of people out here but the the
the flip side of that and or maybe the
uh
the uh the full picture of that is that
a lot of those people are dead inside in
ways you can't even imagine
yeah like their their material successes
do not even they don't belie like the
idea these people are husks cold husks
of human beings that don't like the
success doesn't even matter anymore
because they
they have forgotten
everything that
organically about who they are and
everything and it's interesting and
they're just kind of they're all on like
some like low dose of some type of drugs
you made an interesting point before
when you were driving just talking about
how you you got to pay for you got to
your dads we owe
debts can you get me a lighter please
why aren't there lighters in the studio
wow i mean you know what it is you know
what it is it's it's it's a you want to
talk about
ungrateful
and
like absurd yeah and
oh maybe it's in my car maybe maybe it's
in my car i mean there should be
lighters this year but again it's like
it's it's it's i mean this guy you want
to talk about someone who's went on a
nice ride
i mean you know
i mean anybody can do this ben just so
you know yeah
let's just say all podcast producers
anyone can do your job
and we like very few people yeah very
very people do my job yeah yeah anyone
can do the podcast producer job but they
don't think it's self-taught at this
point the technology is not it's
intuitive they think it's their show
no they they're all of these people from
jamie vernon on down
it's their
you have to they have to feel that way
in order to be good at their job i
remember whatever he's great at his job
but anybody could do it well who would
else be great at his job as an app
anybody a laugh app where i would say
something funny i press it
do that they would do this when i worked
at equinox my last day job ever was uh
was working with equinox selling gym
memberships yeah and every department
they would give you like a braveheart
speech right they'd be like oh the
[ __ ] you know the front desk you guys
are the heartbeaters club you're the
first people that they see without you
guys this club doesn't exist same exact
[ __ ] speech to the sales people same
speech to the group fitness people same
speech to the maintenance people without
the maintenance people yeah without that
without the maintenance people equinox
you're the beating heart of the equinox
maintenance people they did and you'd
see them these old mexican ladies they
they [ __ ] hate this
chest
we are the first line of defense you're
the marines of the toilet
yeah and they would feel but everyone
would have this sense of pride and
together they all came they create a
[ __ ] great business really
legitimately great business so you have
to make he's a front desk
ben is a front desk girl at equinox
that's right that's what he is he's a
hot piece of advice
but he's the [ __ ] first person they
see and he should feel he should feel
important
because it's not a bad job to be they
can hire they can hire another hot girl
sure yeah yeah but
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know what jessica you're here
and you know what it is they could hire
some other big titted [ __ ]
and ben does a lot more he added things
like that but the front desk at equinox
does a lot more too yeah it's not just
checking people in dude they have to i
believe they have to they know the whole
gym they know the property well they
answer them they use the word the
property they have to be like i know the
property and the gen like they yeah they
learn they're the liaison between new
members and the sales people right come
on no yeah they're important it's an
important job jamie vernon like we were
talking once and i i i wanted to and
jamie franzik you know our show and our
show and i go
you say our show excuse me
excuse me that's what happened to red
band that's why he's on the [ __ ]
outskis right he got too cocky
that's why jamie's jamie needs to not go
down the red band path he's gonna be
producing [ __ ]
well joe what i mean i don't wanna i
don't wanna even get into these
statistics because they're troubling
but it just came out that joe is now
getting 500 listeners an episode
it's over
these are this is the statistics this
isn't me yeah these are statistics i
won't even do the show anymore he calls
me all the time lewis will not dude he
[ __ ] calls me all the time like no
joe beat it i i hoot this new phone how
do we get you in touch with him because
he's not responding to you he will not
respond to me
can we call him right now and ask him
why on speaker
okay
you really know you're not going to he
really will
hello
hi who's this
who is it yeah now he uh who is it i
think we can we can is this lewis
how about this remember how he was going
to sneak anthony comey back into sirius
xm
i didn't i don't so when anthony got
fired from siriusxm yeah he went on jim
and sam
and he was going to sneak anthony back
in like with him oh whole [ __ ] thing
why don't we sneak me in next time he
does one of those fun comic hang
podcasts with ari and normand or tim got
so much faster
i'm just under her coat
that would be a little well you should
move to austin yeah that's it then he
can't avoid me if you move no i mean if
you by the way it would be hilarious if
you moved to austin and he still would
not even acknowledge you no and every
instagram post was like you just like
just bought a house in austin he's like
you know you buy a house doug stanhope
sam helps you buy a house in austin now
yeah you literally get a job doing
maintenance on this building
you're literally pushing a broom in the
building he won't look at me no he won't
even look at you in the face he has two
navy seals stand between him and you at
all times
mudwater is a coffee alternative with
four after genetic mushrooms and
ayurvedic herbs with one seventh the
caffeine is a cup of coffee you get the
energy without the anxiety jitters or
crash of coffee each ingredient was
added with a purpose cacao and chai from
mood and a micro dose of caffeine lion's
mane for alertness cordyceps for to help
your physical performance chaga and
rishi to support your immune system
turmeric for soreness and cinnamon and
antioxidants i love this you love it we
use it it's great we've got energy it's
crazy
i love the taste my favorite ingredient
is lions manx i like to be alert
mudwater is a whole30 approved 100 usda
organic non-gmo gluten-free vegan and
it's kosher certified mud water has
launched their new evening ritual the
rest blend a non-caffeinated tea which
you love that promotes relaxation and
rest because the best morning ritual
starts the night before say with me
sister the best morning ritual
no i didn't mean that really
the best morning rich will start tonight
before go to
mudwater.com that's mud wtr.com
tim mudwater.com tim to support the show
and use code tim for five dollars off
i'm telling you all of these ingredients
were uh curated they were chosen with a
purpose it keeps you alert but you don't
have that crash of coffee
mudwater.com
tim
what about uh
what do you think uh what's gonna happen
now if you
i feel like uh
what is because this whole la podcast
scene is does seem a little bit uh dead
it's gay they're all gay
they're all gay
they're
you know i'm not even and i won't even
name specific names but yeah the whole
drama that's going on in the la
podcasting it's one of the gayest things
i've ever seen this is like high school
level drama
where they're like calling each other
and they're talking [ __ ] and they're
threatening each other and it's like
guys in new york drama is every one of
you can't afford your rent yeah so it's
actually real drama like the new york
podcast is somebody being like i am
homeless it's it's a weird thing yeah
it's a weird thing how everyone is so
poor in new york this is people in
manchester talking [ __ ] about each other
in new york the drama is like my parents
just kicked me off my family plan and
i'm 38.
i'm 38 and i don't have a phone
my roommate moved out i was not able to
secure another roommate for that room
this month
i'm actually going to kill myself
new york dramas like people hang
themselves people try to kill themselves
yeah
my my bet is covered in rat feces
i i just you know what it is i think
about new york do you go to like people
have money too like big jay's got money
big jazz money he's got him he's got
talent he's got a nice apartment jay is
one of the funniest people on but it's
not nice this is what new york new
york's nothing's nice it's like
everything's expensive you're like it's
this sucks it's dirty there's garbage
everywhere in front of your building
money in new york you have to have like
a hundred million dollars it's [ __ ]
wild crazy it's a wild thing you go down
to tribeca one of the most expensive
neighbors in new york yeah everything
looks like [ __ ] dude it looks like a
heroin dead everywhere yeah it's like
this is like one of the most expensive
buildings like what the [ __ ] is going on
it's tiny yeah
it's true it's wild
well it's just a different life yeah
it's a different life and it makes you
funnier
it does
but the funniest people in the world
come from la
yeah
the funniest people in the world are
good-looking surfers and people that are
mixed martial artists
that's where funny comes funny comes
from hot people
l.a just needs to strike
from when hot people get bored
if we know one thing about comedy it's
when a hot person is bored that's when
the genius comes it's true when a hot
person has nothing to do that day they
open their mouth and the genius comes
out yeah the biggest struggle for like
l.a comedians this is the one you hear
it's like it's like dude i struggled
dude i was a doormat at the comedy store
the biggest struggle is when they
actually have to do comedy yeah like the
biggie struggles when i actually have to
do it it's like the vast majority of it
it's like here's a photo with me it's
kind of doing it and then they actually
when people actually like go like do
something
that's why a lot of the funny people out
here whether it's me annie
bill burr and i'm not saying i'm any in
any of the categories of these i'm not
putting us in any category but like
sebastian those are east coast guys yeah
those are the east coast people oh yeah
they're all all the funny ones are east
coast guys right yeah that are
transplants yeah i think i mean nobody's
really from l.a who the [ __ ] from l.a
i don't know yeah none of them are
nobody right well they're just dalia i
guess
delia is from l.a yeah and he's funny
i don't really know his stand up that
well i don't either i don't think i've
ever heard him tell a joke
he's a funny guy no i think what he does
to women is funny
i'm a fan
i'm a fan of that
i said women
they're all adults i backed them up on
this
these young women
i feel bad for the guy it's like it's
like we all got to pretend that hot that
18 year olds aren't hot right yeah
they're hot tim by the way tim dillon
his view from his i don't want to give
too much information but it's directly
into beverly hills high school into the
cafeteria you look down here i have a
sponsorship program
before it's like 17 years
by the way you know what's funny i'm
texting true geordie you know him
this massive busy british guy yeah i
think cause it's a i i have this irish
twink i talked to and i hang out with
i'm texting trajority i think it's the
irish twink
literally this is the this is
the conversation i have with true jordy
that was i swear to god i'm reading
i'm reading
the conversation okay
um
listen to this i'm not even kidding he
goes this branded child versus bobby
leash is wild bro it's a car crash hope
you're in the uk soon and then i go i'm
gonna
call you in an hour i said call me when
you wake up winky face we'll plant it
jordy he goes sweet thanks
so i think then he goes then he texts me
he goes you awake bro you know what he
looks like
he's
fine get him to jordy i swear to god
look at true jordy okay
this guy's this is what you want oh no
you want a twink you don't like yeah no
but this guy's a tank listen to this he
texts me
i text him right i go
you awake bro
you awake bro ready he texted me back
yeah just listen to your podcast about
brendan raping you i'm crying laughing i
text him back you're allowed to rape me
you're allowed to rape me
he takes me back i know because you
won't say anything because you want it
to be about the work i respect that lol
he goes you know when you may be in
london i go i'm flying you here did you
forget
he doesn't understand you're stroking
your [ __ ] though
yeah you are masturbating while you're
doing this
it was in my hand maybe and then i go
i'm flying here did you forget now i
start to worry i'm like is this twink
does he have like a dementia which i'm
fine with but he goes i go oh who is
this and he goes oh true jordy brian i'm
like oh my god
how embarrassing
i felt really embarrassed about that
that's hilarious but
you know nothing's nothing chris did is
proven no so the reality is i'm a person
where i go hey also i don't think what
he did
was it wasn't illegal and i don't give a
[ __ ] if you think a guy's creepy
it doesn't matter i don't [ __ ] care
dude and there's a lot of [ __ ]
there's a lot of creepy people in fact
most people are creepy the worst you
just don't know about their [ __ ]
creepiness louis ck it was just being a
creep right creepy a little creepy dude
be a little [ __ ] it happens dude it's
it's the worst thing delia did was that
he produced the school play
it's the worst thing he did was he he i
think he funded and produced his school
play
i don't i don't actually know that he
did anything
my understanding when it was never been
proven it was all like 18 or 19 girls it
was like a girl that was like 17. i
guess when we found out she was 17. this
is he always said this was the creepiest
thing that he did right he found she was
17 then like a year later yeah after she
had turned 18 he hit her up again
and that's a little bit it's a little
bit it's good memory it's not but it's
not [ __ ] grooming it's not a teacher
he's not a [ __ ] person in his life
dude he likes hot young girls
right most guys like hot young girls
most guys don't have the opportunity to
get hot young girls right so they they
go they deal with their [ __ ] hey
[ __ ] tag-wise
[Laughter]
and so nothing was proven yeah and
even if whatever was proven i think
everything that he was accused of was
just sort of him being a little bit of a
douchey
creepy dude which most guys are right
most guys most guys are way [ __ ]
worse than that to be honest with you
most guys are [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] um
so i don't i never really
you know i think it's kind of funny i
think it's all funny like i tease these
guys and i talk about the stuff on my
shows and i think a lot of people in la
think that like legion of skanks and me
like we like are trying to troll them
and it's like no dude it's just sort of
the elephant in the room it's a story
when calvin gets [ __ ] canceled for
something it's a big story in comedy and
to not talk about it and not talk about
it in a funny way it's a story where
it's like
20 years ago yeah
it you know listen i don't whatever
everyone's experiences and i've talked
about it before where i go is it
possible
that he had one idea of the night she
had another idea i'm sure very possible
very popular and this was not
what it's being portrayed as
uh and that when we look at those
dynamics of people that meet up maybe
they're drinking they hook up and then
you know you 20 years also soulless
actors there's la solas i mean
this is my thing with meghan markle
she's like oh they're racist and i'm
like of course you're racist but you're
an actress yeah so i don't i can't
believe i'm gonna believe you
i'm choosing between the british
reptilian royal family and an la actress
they're the same person yeah i'm like
these you know
yeah it's uh
yeah i feel you know a lot of it's it's
just a silly
they they got so it's almost like you
say like i know pete davidson pretty
well right yeah
and sometimes i'll talk about him on my
show
and i feel bad sometimes because i'm
like i really like i've always really
liked pete always been a really sweet
heart of a guy right but he's so famous
that it's i'm not talking about the pete
davidson that i knew from the comedy
scene i'm talking about this celebrity
thing that's [ __ ] kim kardashian and
roasting kanye it's like it's so much
bigger than and and i would feel bad if
pete's never heard us like talking [ __ ]
right it's not even really talking [ __ ]
it's just sort of poking fun and making
fun of the whole situation yeah um he
might come to me one day like hey dude
why would you say that like hurt my
feelings
and i was like
dude you don't have feelings anymore
you're famous you're all right you're a
billionaire you just gotta get release
yourself and also like i don't really
feel bad for people that are [ __ ]
millionaires that get made fun of online
i don't feel bad for you that's right
you that's that's your [ __ ] biggest
problem i feel bad is that people on the
reddit are saying mean words are you out
of your [ __ ] mind you're a
millionaire right and you care about
what somebody on reddit says there are
people that you cannot eat yeah there
are people that don't have the money to
pay their rent they cannot get their
kids insulin
right
now so those those people my audience
we know them
jeremiah watkins is doing the star match
in l.a
trying to show people
he's flipping signs he's just trying to
show people
he's selling fruit with mexicans right
now on the freeway jeremiah watkins is
trying to sell bottles of water on the
405.
so the reality is it's you know
those are the people you go it's you
know
people could say whatever they want
it's just kind of like i learned a long
time ago i have a very thick skin i get
trolls i got i got trolled by the opie
anthony subreddit years ago to the point
where like i was posting i was going
back at them and it was like they went
[ __ ] dude they i mean it was like they
made their own subreddits that were
dedicated to me right and it just
literally gave me a thick skin to it
right there's nothing that anybody could
say there's no work here's here's what's
happening this is the physical action a
stranger somewhere in the world is going
like this
right whether they're good words or bad
words the physical action actually what
it is my name tim dillon is the same
name as a guy who works at marvel and
literally in his twitter handle he says
not the comedian yeah because all day
every day
people just tweeted this guy and go
you're fat i hope you get hated
you're a fascist
you piece of [ __ ] you sat next to alex
jones you did a podcast and this guy's
like i don't know what's happening yeah
dude
i'm uh yeah i'm an artist you're the
same thing there's a guy named uh jon
jones yeah who's not jon jones a fighter
right but like every time jon jones gets
into some more trouble he gets like a
hundred messages and you know same thing
not jon jones the fighter
it's like yeah it's [ __ ] uh it's a
difficult you got to develop a
thanksgiving you you lean into it you
and when objectively speaking
trolling is funny it's really funny
there's a great moment in south park do
you remember do you know how much you
watch south park not a ton but i know
it's brilliant i watched a bunch of it
there was a series they did it was a few
episodes in a row where they were where
the dad became an internet troll yeah it
was [ __ ] hilarious dude it's so funny
when he's
and he's trying to get somebody to
understand it whoever it is they ask him
they're like why are you doing this
this is so dumb what are you doing why
would you do this
and he just he he almost loses control
he's like because it's funny yeah and he
just can't like he it's right
people that don't get that it's like
frustrating
there's a lot of people out there you
got free time yeah you're bored
it's it's a fun way to [ __ ] with people
right yeah and you are
many of those people maybe are not
doing
uh what they want per se maybe they're
like working at a job that's kind of
boring and it's not that fulfilling and
they go online and they [ __ ] with it
entertaining is [ __ ] entertaining i
do it every time when i'm on a flight
every time i'm on a flight i'm bored for
five hours i just sit there and i start
just trolling and arguing back and forth
with people it's so fun and so silly so
if you separate yourself from it and
realize that it's just a stranger saying
something that's probably not valid
then [ __ ] the problem is when it's
valid i think it starts to affect people
and that'll happen sometimes people will
they'll pull on a thread and they they
get something you go oh that one
actually hurt a little bit
right yeah yeah well i think that's part
of it and i also think part of the
problem is like there isn't an element
of like people going like here's your
house you know what i mean yeah here's
your address here's where you go
there was an article that came out that
said i was a proud boy right this
completely fabricated article right um
actually it wasn't fabricated okay i am
a proud boy
i'm the leader of the new jersey chapter
no problems yeah no what happened was
there was a bunch of proud boys that
were fans of like legion of scandals of
course if people don't know the the you
know gavin mcgann has started proud boys
while he was on anthony comey's network
now my podcast was also an anthony
company's network at the same time so it
was just a ton of crossover sure and
they started this group as like a
[ __ ] gag at first like they were
trying to be and then it turned into
something super politicized and super
like they were going out to to be
counter pro if you're a [ __ ] funny
group but you're counter protesting you
got to look in the mirror you're like oh
you're not a funny group it's not about
cereal it's not about punching each
other in the arm right if you're counter
protesting in [ __ ] riot gear then
it's something different than that i'm
not even necessarily demonizing that
[ __ ] no go [ __ ] go you want to go
fight in a portland park have fun have
at it
you guys can beat the [ __ ] out of each
other with bike locks like give a [ __ ] a
nice weekend i enjoy watching it online
right so there was a bunch of proud boys
though that were fans of like legion of
skanks and there were fans of us
and they had a blog like some proud boy
newsletter right
um and after i fought at ls mania they
named me proud boy of the month
right right probably of the month the
context is they were just naming they
were you know naming whoever whoever
right they they would they would have
said it was the rock had the rock you
know done something that you know they
were a fan of his um so that came out
and i hit them up i was like dude what
the [ __ ] are you doing i was like if
you're a fan of mine you would
understand why this would be right and
i've never i'm not i'm not [ __ ] on
the proud boys am i [ __ ] on what
they do but let's get real dude you it's
it's a [ __ ] scarlet letter you're
involved with that and you have nothing
to do with it you want to wear that
scarlet letter wear that scarlet letter
all [ __ ] day long dude and i'm not
going to kick you out of my show for
wearing a proud boy's hat i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't even know what that even is
the same way i wouldn't kick somebody
out for wearing a [ __ ] antifa [ __ ]
i don't kick any you pay the money i
don't kick anyone i don't give a [ __ ]
you start yelling yeah yelling [ __ ] then
it's over right yeah so i hit the guy up
i was like dude you got to take that
down that's crazy but the internet is
forever and
you know people you know they use i
guess some sort of like way back machine
or whatever and they found this article
specifically and then they you know they
wrote a whole thing about how i'm a
proud boy they said this tattoo on my
arm was uh because i'm a fourth degree
proud boy yeah it's just bad it's the
number four it's just a shitty tattoo no
it's a good tattoo it's actually it
represents chaos theory it's a double
pendulum it's not even a number four
it's a double pendulum which makes this
design which represents chaos theory did
your mom get that for you
no it's uh no i got i i mean you know no
i got this for my son i got this for my
career i got it for everything we could
be anywhere right now tim so that would
be the infinite amount of decisions that
we could have made in our lives yeah
literally dude it's crazy the fact that
me and you are sitting here or crossing
each other is an actual crea it's so
unlikely the fact that ben's here the
fact that these lights are here it's so
unlikely that it's a small [ __ ]
miracle right and that's what this
tattoo represents yeah not a [ __ ]
a fourth degree probably which is you
know and so and people just started uh
people some guy wrote an article yeah
then they they share it and then they
were like you know proud boy lives in
this town in new jersey um they actually
have the town wrong which is funny
because i have a generic name i think
they found a different louis gomez right
um
but it was still like i was like and
then uh you know i won't even say his
name but one of you know one of the
comics that sort of trolls me online
back in new york yeah um
[Music]
he started posting about it and he said
he started retweeting the article and
that's why i really started having a
[ __ ] big problem with this kid
because like no i do have a family i do
have a house your intent that's when it
goes too far your [ __ ] intent is to
put my address out yes so maybe somebody
will see me and come up to me and my
family
what do you think's gonna [ __ ] happen
there right what the [ __ ] do you think
is gonna happen if somebody comes up to
me and my [ __ ] family yeah that's a
crazy thing to do especially and this is
my problem with that kid specifically he
knew i wasn't a proud boy he knew what
was going on like he was completely
aware and that's where i go that's the
[ __ ] responsibility just be real
that's when it goes too far yeah that's
when it's too far yeah and i'm not
[ __ ] i would never give out
somebody's address i would never i know
we make jokes about doxxing people no i
don't really want people to to do that
[ __ ] um but it's uh it's [ __ ] hot in
the kitchen dude it really is and in a
weird way i'm you know after trump left
now it's cooled down a little bit
because i feel like the people on the
left they feel like they gotta they
don't feel like they have to fight so
hard got a little bit of a w comedy's
sort of lower on the rung of priorities
yeah as it should be
as it should be yeah but if trump runs
again it's gonna get hot in the kitchen
it's gonna get hot in the kitchen and
make it so hot where it's like it's uh
it's scalding yeah and i don't give a
[ __ ] about politics so right you know
you know none of us too none of us do we
all have ideas and values and things but
then we also realize our job and this is
the problem is like
you know you're gonna have fans that
believe everything yeah
i have fans that believe trump's hitler
i have fans that believe trump's the
greatest president that's ever lived
it's not my business i don't really care
what my fans believe yeah i care that
i'm doing my job i care what i believe
i don't give a [ __ ] what the people in
the audience believe how do i even how
would i even know it's inconsequential
for me right in my game that i'm playing
who the president is right if the
president whoever the president is and
this is what you know we said before
about gas prices right it's
inconsequential if that's where my my
like i'm focused on those things
everything from gas prices to who the
president is all this [ __ ] that i truly
really can't control i know that you can
right you can't i'm i'm hyper focused on
playing my game and sort of moving
forward and those are variables that
have very little effect on whether or
not i'm moving forward that's right
yeah
louis gomez where can the people
find you where can they
where can the people support what you're
doing is skankfest completely sold out
skankfest completely sold out
how many tickets do you sell we do 2500
people per day okay so versus exclusive
very exclusive it's not um it feels like
a big party it's one venue four rooms
going on at the same time
you're special
yeah my special's up my old ones up on
youtube i'm doing i think we're doing uh
gas digital is going to produce six half
hour specials this summer and i'm gonna
do another half hour four gas digital uh
the the gringo poppy way buy my special
we'll put it on gas digital you should
just buy it buy it flat out you should
just buy a flat i'll sell it to you 500
put it on gaston let's go
i was thinking no we're gonna we're
gonna put it back on youtube we're gonna
put them out on youtube there'll be an
extended cut on gas digital uncensored
extended a few more jobs how are you
gonna choose the comics um we have
rebecca trent and christine
evans or uh executive producing and um
you know yeah they produce skankfest
with me so i think we're gonna do one
with me dave looks like maybe mike
racine aronberg
okay a few killers yeah yeah um probably
six or seven of them so look out for
that uh also i'm on the road a ton right
now go to lewis of skanks.com i'm going
all over california i'm going to san
diego i'm going to ontario i'm going
over texas i'll be in
dallas i'll be in fort worth i'll be in
uh austin [ __ ] ems pennsylvania's
coming up albany's coming up a lot of
stuff coming up lewis of skanks.com me
and aaron berger going on tour all over
the place all this fall aaron burst
hilarious [ __ ] killer one of the
dirtiest comics a great show and uh yeah
check out my podcast i do three podcasts
uh legion of skanks real last podcast
and uma wrap they're all on my network
which is gas digital network.com you
have to subscribe you can just go and
listen to the latest episodes and watch
the latest episodes for free right on
the website
um or you can subscribe on itunes
everywhere else and there's a premium
site as well if you guys uh really like
it you guys want to get the archives and
all that louis gomez thank you for
coming out letting and representing new
york comics podcasters
chopping it up here with us out uh in
l.a
and um
you know we love you guys in new york
and we miss you it's good to see you and
uh i love you timmy i love you guys you
know i have a ton of respect for what
you do i look up to you i look at what
you guys are doing i take influence from
it in very many ways
and uh yeah dude it's [ __ ] it's
really nice well we we also look in the
same way we look down on you guys you
know we absolutely
we look down on you and we appreciate
what you're doing at that level and we
appreciate that louis thank you